Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Azak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz Arsthetik.
Aufnahmegespräch.
Ja, könnten wir zusammen auf das Aufnahmegespräch hören?
Natürlich gerne.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Na klar.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Schmidt.
Herr Schmidt, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestätigen?
Ja, mein Vornamen ist P.V. Paula, E.V. Emil, T.V. Theodor, E.V. Emil, R.V. Richard.
Nachname ist Schmitz, S.V. Siegfried, C.V. Cesar, H.V. Heinrich, M.V. Marta, E.V. Ida, D.V. Dora, T.V. Theodor.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 71 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 11. Januar 1955.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
Okay. Vielen Dank für diese Informationen. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich ungefähr drei Tage sehr starke Durchfälle habe.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie Durch?
Durchfälle.
Haben Sie Durchfall?
Genau.
Zum Beispiel, wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Ja, ungefähr so sieben bis achtmal.
Haben Sie unangenehme Etwas bemerkt? Zum Beispiel Rinde oder Haut?
Ja, das riecht sehr übel.
Haben Sie Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfluss, Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe Übelkeit, ich habe auch etwas Fieber.
Ich habe gestern gemessen, das war bei 38 Grad.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, Bauchkrämpfe habe ich.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Ganz Bauch.
Unterbauch.
Unterbauch Schmerzen.
Rechtsseitig, linksseitig, welche Seite sind Schmerzen?
Beidseitig.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn?
Vorbei zehn untererträglich ist.
Wie stark sind Bauchschmerzen auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn?
Okay.
Ich würde sagen so fünf bis sechs.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Okay.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Haben Sie Blut im Schutul bemält?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemält, nein.
Sie haben Übelkeit?
Ja.
Wie viel Mal haben Sie oder wie oft?
Ich habe Übelkeit.
Ich habe aber nicht erbrochen.
Entschuldigung, ja.
Leiden Sie unter Blasungen oder?
Ja auch, aber der Durchfall ist sehr stark.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Ungewohnheit, der ähnliche Beschwerde hat?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungerollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist weniger geworden jetzt.
Haben Sie an Ihrer Haut Farbeveränderungen bemäht?
Nein.
Leiden Sie oder haben Sie Husten, Atemnot?
Nein, auch nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzkorpfen, Herzkörpern?
Nein, aber ich habe ein bisschen Schwinde, wenn ich aufstehe und wenn ich mir setze.
Ich denke, ich muss mehr trinken.
Sie haben Schwitzen?
Nein, Schwitzen, nein Schwinde.
Schwinde, Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Erstgewohnheiten?
Nein, ich esse eigentlich alles.
Zum Beispiel Vegetarisch oder?
Nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich schlafe gut, aber ich muss jetzt ein, zwei Mal aufstehen, weil ich Durchfall habe.
Trinken Sie genügend Wasser?
Ich denke nicht, ich muss mehr trinken wahrscheinlich.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerde gehabt?
So starken Durchfall habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sind diese Beschwerde nach einem bestimmten Essen, nach einem bestimmten Essen, ein bisschen zu spät?
Aufgetreten, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, ich denke nicht.
Zum Beispiel Milch?
Nein.
Oder Brötchen?
Nein, ich habe nichts Besonderes gegessen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit einen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, aber ich war im Krankenhaus vor ungefähr zwei Wochen.
Vor zwei Wochen?
Ich war im Krankenhaus.
Warum?
Ich hatte eine Bronchitis.
Vor zwei Wochen, ja Bronchitis.
Welche therapeutischen Maßnahmen wurden bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Ich habe Antibiotik bekommen.
Hatten Sie Probleme nach der Antibiotik?
Habe ich was?
Hatten Sie Probleme nach der antibiotischen Behandlung?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Herr Schmidt, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Ich habe das schon seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren?
Ja.
Noch etwas?
Ich habe Knie Schmerzen, ich habe Arthrose in den Knien.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr seit zehn Jahren.
Gibt es noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Das reicht schon.
Was?
Das reicht.
Das ist schon genug.
Ah, ich habe fast verstanden.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, mir wurde einmal der Blinden in meiner Kindheit rausgenommen.
Okay.
Noch etwas?
Nein.
Okay.
Wurde bei Ihnen außer Bronchitis im Krankenhaus bleiben oder die Stationäre behandelt?
Ja, ich war stationär.
Ich war ungefähr zehn Tage im Krankenhaus.
Ja.
Wurden bei Ihnen außer Bronchitis weitere Stationäre behandelt?
Ich war wegen einer Bronchitis im Krankenhaus.
Ah, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Schmitz, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme für meinen Blutdruck ein Medikament ein und für meine Schmerzen nehme ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Können Sie mir die Namen von Medikamenten sagen?
Erst einmal Amnodipin, fünf Milligramm.
Okay.
Wie oft nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Morgen und abends.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich Ibuprofen ein, morgens und abends.
Kennen Sie Dosierung von Ibuprofen?
Ja, 400 Milligramm und ich nehme Pantoprazole ein, morgens einmal.
Kennen Sie Dosierung von Pantoprazole?
20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm, okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, nicht als Justus.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Das ist sehr gut für Ihre Gesundheit.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gar nicht.
Okay, super.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Dafür bin ich zu alt.
Wann und wie haben Sie konsumiert?
Ich habe nicht konsumiert.
Ich bin dafür zu alt.
Ah, ja, okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine relevante Erkrankung?
Ich denke nicht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Frau, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Herr Schmidt, ich glaube, Sie sind Retner, richtig?
Ich bin Retner, ja.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht als Arbeit?
Ich war Altenpfleger.
Mit wem leben Sie so seit?
Mit meiner Frau.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig, nicht?
Ja.
Gut, super.
Tragen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich gehe sehr gerne spazieren.
Okay.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Haben Sie Stress im Privatleben?
Eigentlich nicht, mir geht es gut normalerweise.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Schmidt, ich habe meine wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich möchte aber, dass Sie mir helfen.
Ich bin sehr schwach.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen helfen, wenn Sie sich keine Sorgen machen.
Bitte legen Sie sich auf die Liege.
Ich werde Sie förderlich untersuchen.
Dankeschön.
Hat jemand andere Fragen?
Ja, danke.
Bitte schön.
Wie sah Ihr Stül aus?
Flüssig.
Wässrig.
Welche Antibiotika haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich glaube, das waren Kinder mit 10.
Haben Sie vor oder nach dem Essen Bauchkrämpfe?
Ich habe immer Bauchkrämpfe, die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit.
Haben Sie noch Auswuchs oder etwas?
Nein.
Keine Lunge Symptome?
Nein, keine was?
Keine Lungebeschwerden?
Keine Lunge, nein.
Haben Sie Rohesfleisch, Mayonnaise, Eier gegessen?
Rohesfleisch nicht, aber Eier, Mayonnaise esse ich gerne.
Aber das ist nichts Besonderes, das esse ich immer.
Immer, ja okay.
Entschuldigung, wie viele Mal haben Sie die Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe gestern und vorgestern gemessen.
Gestern und vorgestern.
Ich bin bereit.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und möchte ihn Ihnen vorstellen.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Sehr schön.
Danke.
Unser Patient heißt Peter Schmid.
Er ist 71 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß und wiegt 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Schmid stellte sich heute aufgrund seit drei Tagen bestehende, persistierende,
progresive Diary bei uns vor.
Nach Angaben des Patienten ist die Diary, nein, nach Angaben des Patienten
geht der Patient 7-8 Mal auf die Toilette.
Außerdem klagt der Patient über Fieber mit 38 Grad, Vertigo und Nausea.
Der Patient teilt mit, dass er unter Bauchschmerzen leidet.
Die Schmerzen sind im Ganzunterbauch.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde von Patienten 5-6 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala bewertet.
Der Patient gab an, dass die Diary wasrig und überwiegend ist.
Nach Angaben des Patienten wurde bei den Patienten vor zwei Wochen gegen Bronchitis eine Antibiotische Therapie durchgeführt.
Die Fragen nach Hemathemes, Melena und einer bestimmten Auslöser wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative Anemnese ist unauffällig bis auf Inapetens.
In Besuch auf Vorerkrankungen leidet der Patient seit 20 Jahren an Arteriella hypertonica, seit 10 Jahren an Gonarthros.
Bei den Patienten wurde in seiner Kindheit eine Apendektomie durchgeführt.
Besuchlichtermedikation nimmt er am Lotipin 5 mg morgens und abends, Ibuprofen 400 mg morgens und abends, sowie Pantoprasol 20 mg morgens ein.
Bei den Patienten sind keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Warum nimmt der Patient Pantoprazole ein?
Warum? Wegen Magenschutz. Der Patient nimmt mehrmals Analgetikum, Ibuprofen ein.
Deswegen nimmt der Patient diese Medikamente.
Die Niko-Tin-Konsum, Alkoholkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Die Eltern von den Patienten sind gesund. Er ist ein Einzelkind.
Die Eltern sind gesund?
Beide Eltern sind gesund.
Leben die noch?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Wahrscheinlich sind die schon gestorben.
Ja, richtig.
Ich werde diese Frage bei der Untersuchung nachholen.
Herr Schmidt ist verheiratet und hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Zurzeit ist er Rentner, aber früher hat er als Altenpflege gearbeitet.
Die Reiseanämnisse ist unauffällig. Er ist vollständig gengt.
Er geht spazieren.
Herr Oberast, die anämnistischen Angaben...
War er schon beim Haushalt gewesen?
Entschuldigung, bitte?
War er wegen den Beschwerden schon bei seinem Hausarzt gewesen?
Nein, Herr Schmidt hat im Laufe der Zeit nicht andere Hausarzt aufgesucht.
Okay.
Die anämnistischen Angaben deuten am besten auf eine akute Gastroenteritis hin, da der Patient typische Symptome aufweist.
Zum Beispiel mehrere Diare und Fieber und ganzes Defuse Bauchschmerzen.
Die anämnistischen Angaben kommen in chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung.
Das ist im Alter aber selten, 71 Jahre alt.
Selten.
Ja, richtig.
Und eine Divertikulitis.
Ja, kann sein. Aber Divertikulitis macht normalerweise nicht diese hohen Durchfälle.
Gastroenteritis war richtig oder Enteritis war richtig denke ich. Aber was für ein Enteritis könnte das sein? Ganz typisch.
In diesem Fall?
Ja, in diesem Fall.
Vor zwei Wochen hat der Patient eine antibiotische Antibiotikum verarbeitet.
Er hat eine antibiotische Therapie erhalten.
Ja, erhalten. Deswegen können wir eine antibiotische Nebenwirkung von antibiotisch sagen.
Keine Nebenwirkung, nicht eine Nebenwirkung, aber eine sogenannte antibiotikassoziierte Enteritis gibt es.
In Deutschland sehr oft muss man sagen, bei älteren Patienten.
Welche, wie nennt man diese Enteritis? Sie hat einen bestimmten Namen.
Übel riechende Durchfälle, häufige, hohes Alter nach Antibiotika-Gabe.
Wie nennt man diese? Eine Pseudomembranosekulitis bzw. Clostridien-Enteritis durch Clostridien verursacht. Kennen Sie das?
Meinen Sie als Erreger?
Richtig.
Ja, Clostridium difficile.
Ja, ich weiß.
Clostridium difficile bzw. das Clostridium difficile Toxin. Richtig, kennen Sie das?
Nein, ganz typisch. Hohes Alter, Krankenhausaufenthalt, Antibiotikum, hat sogar Pantoprazole, Kinder mit Ziehen bekommen.
Das sind alles so Faktoren, die für eine Clostridien-Enteritis sprechen.
Ja, vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Was machen wir denn mit den Patienten zur Diagnostik?
Ja, zunächst würde ich bei den Patienten die Vitalparameter kontrollieren und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Haut von Patienten inspizieren.
Außerdem würde ich bei der körperlichen Untersuchung ob Abwechspannung, Druckdolenz, Dostlatschmerz oder Organe Magari vorlegen.
Richtig.
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich eine Labo-Untersuchung durchführen.
Und Blutbild-Ersundung-Parameter, CRP, Nieren- und Leberwerte und Stuhlprobe.
Elektrolyte nicht vergessen, ganz wichtig. Der Patient hat Durchfall, er verliert viele Salze.
Ich würde die Abdomen-Zonographie durchführen, um die inneren Organe zu beurteilen.
Natürlich würde ich eine digitale und rechte Untersuchung durchführen.
Machen Sie das immer wenn jemand Durchfall hat?
Oder warum machen Sie das?
Der Patient ist alt.
Ja, kann man machen.
Wenn man die Differenzialdiagnose stenozierender Tumor hat, der auch Durchfall machen kann, kann man machen.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie noch?
Durchfall? Ich würde die komputerisierte Tomographie des Abdomens.
Durchfall? Was machen Sie?
Ich habe einen Stuhlprobe-Test bestimmen lassen.
Genau, eine Stuhlprobe. Und was lassen Sie kontrollieren?
Bei der Stuhlprobe kontrolliere ich Erreger und Blut.
Auch was noch? Sie können auch Entzündungsparameter messen.
Meinen Sie Lokosythen?
Keilprotektin.
Das ist ein Marker, der im Darm produziert wird, ob eine Entzündung vorliegt oder nicht.
Können Sie noch mal nachlesen?
Aber Sie lassen natürlich auch Clostridin bestimmen, weil Sie haben den Verdacht auf eine Clostridin-Intervips.
Bei der Stuhlprobe können wir die Erreger feststellen.
Genau. Und was machen Sie therapeutisch bei den Patienten?
Herr Oberath, sollte sich meine Verdachtstherapeutie bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Die Stuhlprobe haben Sie ja noch nicht sofort. Die Stuhlprobe dauert zwei Tage.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf oder nicht?
Ja, der Patient hat mehr Diarrhea. Deswegen hat der Patient mehr oder zu viel Flüssigkeit verloren.
Genau. Was müssten Sie denn machen?
Deswegen würde ich den Patienten ausreichende Flüssigkeit oder massive Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Wie denn? Trinken oder intravenös?
Ja, einen venösen Zugang legen. Dabei würde ich ein Antibiotikum und Antiemetikum.
Und gegen Klebsialia ein Antibiotikum verabreichen.
Kein Antibiotikum mehr ein seit zehn Tagen. Aber würden Sie jetzt schon Antibiotikum geben, ohne zu wissen, was er hat?
Ja, deswegen würde ich eine Antibiotik in der Kultur.
Ja genau, haben Sie ja gemacht. Stuhlprobe. Aber dauert zwei Tage. Sie wissen es noch nicht.
Sie wissen noch nicht, ob er Kostriden hat oder etwas anderes.
Ein Antibiotikum jetzt schon geben würde ich nicht machen. Ich würde ein Antibiotikum geben, wenn Sie das Ergebnis haben. Also nach zwei Tagen.
Aber dahin können Sie schon intravenöse Flüssigkeitzugabe geben. Das reicht schon aus.
Und natürlich würde ich eine sehr hohe Entzündungswerte haben.
Sehr hohe. Dann kann man Antibiotikum überlegen.
Ja, deswegen würde ich eine symptomatische Therapie behandeln.
Dann nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf. Was müssen Sie bei dem Patienten aufpassen, wenn Sie ihn stationär aufnehmen?
Er hat Durchfall. Er muss also isoliert werden. Der Patient muss stationär isoliert werden, allein im Zimmer.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Jetzt mal zwei Tage das Ergebnis haben mit Kostriden entterritten. Welches Antibiotikum geben Sie dann?
Kostridium.
Dann geben Sie Vancomycin.
Wenn wir erregt feststellen.
Wenn wir Kostridium-Verdacht bestätigt haben, dann ja. Dann bekommen wir Vancomycin.
Okay.
Nach der Akutbehandlung empfehlen wir den Patienten persönliche Hygiene, gesunde Ernährung.
Das empfehlen wir sowieso. Das hat nichts mit Ernährung zu tun.
Kostridium hat nichts mit Ernährung zu tun. Hat mit Antibiotika zu tun.
Ja, ja. Wir müssen unsere Händeflüssigkeit trinken.
Kostridium wird mit Antibiotika behandelt.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Okay. Also Patienten stationär aufnehmen, Flüssigkeit geben, Blutwerte kontrollieren, Stuhlprobe kontrollieren.
Wenn die Stuhlprobe positiv auf Kostridium ist, Antibiotikum geben.
Als Antibiotikum würden wir Vancomycin verbrechen.
Ganz genau. Wir geben Vancomycin für mindestens 10 Tage. Okay?
Okay.
Gibt es Fragen?
Muss Vancomycin im Krankenhaus weitergeben?
Ja.
Yvonne oder seit drei Tagen?
Oral. Nicht Yvonne, Oral.
Okay. Muss Arzt Leben oder Nierenwerte kontrollieren, gleichzeitig Vancomycin?
Natürlich.
Welche Werte?
Welche Leben oder Nierenwerte?
Beide Werte.
Und normalerweise, vielleicht falsch weiß ich, normalerweise nach dem Antibiotikum nutzen warten wir die Röhr ungefähr innerhalb drei Tagen. Ja?
Aber dieser Mann, ungefähr vor zwei Wochen Antibiotikum nutzen, aber nicht innerhalb drei Tagen hat er Durchfall.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Normalerweise ist das früher. Sie haben recht. Innerhalb von drei bis fünf Tagen. Aber dieser Part hat das später bekommen. Man muss also dran denken.
Ja?
Okay. Wie kann man zum Beispiel Vibrio cholera ausschließen?
Können Sie auch Stuhlprobe machen?
Nur Stuhlprobe. Okay.
Aber Cholera ist sehr selten in Deutschland.
Ja.
Der Keitler ist aber nicht hier.
Oder, und vielleicht mehr erhöhte Fieber mit Cholera oder?
Cholera ist selten in Deutschland. Der war nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Also vorher soll er Cholera bekommen. Es gibt keine erhöhte Infektionszahlen hier in Deutschland.
Okay.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich Kostridien.
Er kann auch Salmonellen haben. Salmonellen zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Aber das macht nicht die Oberdurchfallrate und auch nicht diese Beschwerden.
Okay. Und ist es hilfreich, dass Probiotikum anfangen oder?
Vielleicht.
Okay. Danke.
Entschuldigung. Erwartung, wie die Diagnose ist?
Die Diagnose ist Kostridien enttäglich. Oder Pseudomembranose Colitis.
Wenn man das richtig weiß.
Normalerweise erwarten wir die Fieber beim Pseudomembranose Colitis.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden. Normal.
Normalerweise erwarten wir Fieber beim Pseudomembranose Colitis. Ist das normal?
Ja. Ja. Am die Ort.
Erhöht die Temperaturen. Ja.
Danke.
Wegen der Hydratation vielleicht ja.
Bitte?
Ja. Vielleicht.
Aufgrund Fieber. Vielleicht auch der Hydratation.
Natürlich. Ganz genau. Richtig.
Und wenig trinken.
Er ist auch nicht jung. Er ist älter. 71 Jahre alt.
Dann vergisst man auch trinken manchmal.